وُلد في تايلاند عام 1958 قبل أن
ينخرط في كرة القدم ، اشتهر V shy Siwon وهو
مناسب بتأسيس
شركة Giants Qing المعفاة من الرسوم الجمركية في عام 1989
والتي نمت إلى مكانة بارزة في وطنه
كمجموعة رائدة في مجال السفر بالتجزئة
وجعلته أحد أغنى الناس  في
تايلاند ، اشترى ليستر سيتي في عام
2010 مقابل سبعين مليون
دولار عندما كان الفريق في إنجلترا من
الدرجة الثانية
، وقد عاد الفريق المعروف باسم الثعالب إلى
دوري الدرجة الأولى في الدوري الإنجليزي الممتاز في عام
ولكن لم يكن يعتبر  قوة في
كرة القدم الإنجليزية ومغازلة مع
خفض رتبتها إلى الدرجة الأدنى
على الرغم من ثروات الفريق المتقلبة
في الملعب بعيدًا عن ذلك بفضل
دعمه c / y من أصبح شخصًا
مشهورًا بشكل كبير في Lester Lester
بدأ موسم 2015-16 حيث  5000 إلى 1 من
الغرباء للفوز
باللقب وإنتاج أعظم
حكاية خرافية في تاريخ الدوري
الإنجليزي الممتاز وربما كرة القدم الإنجليزية
نفسها من خلال المضي قدمًا في الفوز باللقب  متقدم
بعشر نقاط بقيادة المدرب الإيطالي المخضرم
كلاوديو رانييري ، لم يكن فريقه
يحتوي على نجوم حقيقيين ، لكنه مزج
المواهب المثيرة مثل المهاجم جيمي
فاردي والجناح الذي قام بتربية ماريز مع بعض
اللاعبين الأكبر سنًا ذوي الخبرة ،
وكانت النتائج مذهلة نظرًا
لروح الفريق المذهلة والعروض المهيمنة.
الثعالب على قمة
كرة القدم الإنجليزية وجعل جميع الأساطير المشاركين
في العملية ، كانت الاحتفالات في
ليستر وكذلك في تايلاند
لا تُنسى حقًا ، بينما
كان من غير المرجح تحقيق النجاح اللاحق من هذا القبيل
في دوري
تحكمه تقليديًا الأندية الكبيرة الموجودة  في
شمال غرب إنجلترا بالإضافة إلى
العاصمة C كان إرثًا مناسبًا مع
ليستر لا يمكن الاستهانة
به الآن على قناة CNN باتريك